Michael let me get to you you play well
in Alien who's kind of a reptilian is
that fair to say yeah he is superior
alien race yeah yours the reptile race
about the superior alien races yeah and
what I'm impressed with is on the show
you have to be a deep deep deep green
all the time when your character is in
that state yeah and it looks like they
almost tattoo you with that color like
it would be very hard for it to come off
yeah that's exactly the case there's
it's like two and a half to three hours
of gluing silicone on my head and my
face and then coloring the parts that
aren't already green green and the Green
life right do you do you have children
yeah I have a six-year-old son okay have
you allowed your six-year-old son to see
you that way I introduced him to it
slowly so I texted my wife a picture
first and then we talked on the phone
and then we Skyped and methods but it
didn't help
like he freaked out as he could hear my
voice but it wasn't me and I and when
I'm in it the crew who's been working
with me for months are like treating me
like I'm got a new guy on the show they
have no idea it's me even though it
sounds like me right yeah well you
should have said to your son to calm him
down is no it's still your daddy I've
just been eaten by this thing season 2
season 2 we're gonna get to that Ken let
me ask you something
well first let's see you as Jeb because
this is this is let's see you as Jeff
the gray from the show there you are
that is quite a look that you have to be
wearing all the time pretty intense
pretty intensive let's get in tight I
think we have a tighter shot there we go
why are there little hairs well that's
it coming off the top of your head it
doesn't look very ball sadness oh yeah
we all understood what it would it meant
you just said it's great ball sack I
said ball sack ish oboe that's it oh
then I'm the crude one yeah that's most
people's read most people are horrified
when they see how that in the first five
seconds but then they totally get used
to it and literally you have a giant
testicle in red once the ice is cracked
everything's okay they don't look at my
eyes they kind of look around yeah yeah
Bjorn you are also an alien
you are as this correct you are from
sweet yeah just blue the rest of us away
you know what's interesting is that I
was just in Norway mm-hmm and and so I
had the experience of meeting many
people that look a lot like you no no
that's a weird topic that's a compliment
yeah there's a very very good-looking
group of people that's all I'm saying I
am coming on to you
did the casting directors when they cast
you know that you were Swedish uh no
they didn't know that's it no I went I
actually they actually asked me after my
audition like are you are you trying to
do an accent no way no this is
unfortunately the way I speak I thought
I wasn't doing you're doing an accent
right now because I saw the same thing
in Norway they speak English beautifully
but with this slight accent and if I
didn't know any better I would think
they were Americans that were making fun
of me that's a tiny little bit of a
thing and you feel like are you screwing
with me and then I realized that was in
Norway yeah yeah I haven't tried to
speak a lot of English with Swedes or
Norwegians like I usually just go for
Swedish so I don't know right but most
of them are better than me which is kind
of annoying like I call my younger
brother sometimes to ask what like what
does this mean and he's six years
younger and lives in Sweden still and he
can interpret English for you better
than you can yeah yeah that's very
depressing it's kind of your dad I just
I'm just glad they didn't audition him
well it's clear we should have cast your
brother that's your brother's better I
want to make you something
well it's just true Luka and him try
swear to God if there's any other people
in your family
you